hi I'm Erik Bosse and as we still
recover from Game of Thrones season
seven finale we're left with the mystery
of who will survive the end of the
series we know you promised all men must
die but you know which ones we are gonna
have plenty of time to speculate and
theorize between now and sometime in
2019 when the final season is expected
to air also we just learned HBO is gonna
make it even harder to predict how the
series will end by shooting multiple
alternate endings damn popular TV shows
have been known to do this that even the
cast and crew won't know the real ending
they did it on lost season 4 with which
character was in the coffin and recently
on The Walking Dead with alternate
footage of Meghan killing off all the
other characters so with no possible
leaks to guide us let's fly blind in
predicting whose watch will end in the
final season of Game of Thrones now this
conversation can't just be about
bloodlust
with Game of Thrones deaths of primary
characters need to have meaning like
they must be a natural consequence of a
character's mistakes or flaws or more of
a thematic game-changer like the world
has changed so much that there's no
longer a place in it for a character and
their death signal how much the
survivors world is different okay so
these are the remaining core characters
of the show Daenerys Targaryen Jon Snow
aka Aegon Targaryen Sansa Arya and bran
Stark Cersei Jaime and Tyrion Lannister
the night king Fionan euron greyjoy ser
Davos Seaworth and Samwell Tarly now of
these george RR martin initially planned
for at least five of them to survive at
the end of the book series john danny
arya bran and tyrion but that was just
his plan in the original outline for the
books which were only gonna be three
installments and this is long before the
show existed which changed a lot of
Martin's original intent
so assuming any of the main players can
go whose behavior has made them worthy
of death in the show's eyes or whose
deaths would reflect a crucial shift in
the world of the show obviously Cersei
Lannister is at the top of that list in
my other season eight predictions video
I explored how her complete lack of a
soul and her refusal to take the threat
of the White Walkers seriously could
lead to a scenario where she's shivering
on the Iron Throne ready to poison
herself as a knight King closes in on
her also as the top game player of Game
of Thrones
Cersei doesn't seem like someone who'd
be fun to see in an existential ice
battle like just imagine the game
changer of
the night came plunging a new frozen
sword into the iron throne freezing and
shattering it the game would be over and
so too would be Circe's purpose in the
show the only way Cersei could survive
the final season is if Game of Thrones
ends up restoring itself as the
political drama was in the first couple
seasons by allowing her to live the show
would say hey common humanity is
important all but this is a world where
absolute treachery is the most important
thing in life I guess I could see Game
of Thrones ending as a house of cards
styles in a kool downer but I doubt it
this has become a show about ice zombies
and Dragons and Cersei is not long for
that world Jamie meanwhile may face a
different fate
yes his actions and earlier seasons made
him totally worthy of a death sentence
but you could also argue he's done a lot
to redeem himself and now that he's left
Cersei behind to face the threat up
north I definitely could see Jaime
playing some role in the war to come now
I've speculated in past videos how Jaime
might end up fulfilling the valen Quora
prophecy from the books as the younger
brother that will kill Cersei and some
crazier theories have posed that he
could be the prince that was promised
and of course we all want to see Jaime
fighting tormund for Brienne's love and
the two of them growing old together
honestly I think the biggest obstacle to
all of that for Jaime is brand remember
Brant definitely used his three-eyed
Raven powers to sentence Littlefinger to
death so yeah if Jaime ever makes it a
Winterfell he's gonna have some
explaining to do but I think with a
heartfelt apology or some kind of heroic
rescue it's possible a reformed
Kingslayer could end up surviving this
series now speaking of brand I don't
think he's gonna die in the final season
rather I think season 8 will finally
show brand coming alive if you think
about it bran has been too passive of a
character for these past seven seasons I
think the show has been waiting for this
final supernatural battle against the
night king to finally unleash brands
full powers there's that bull worgen and
two dragons flying through time
summoning an army of weirwood trees to
come alive and smash everything like
ants in Lord of the Rings that's
something he can do right bran has just
suffered so much as a child and I would
just be really surprised if Game of
Thrones decides his whole purpose in
life is to just use his mind powers to
help his family fight a war and then die
prematurely no brands gonna grow old
maybe old enough to be that same
Ravin figure who spoke to him as an old
man because that could totally be brand
because the show never established him
as Brendan rivers the Bloodraven that's
just something from the books huh I just
just think about now Aria I'm less sure
about I know George or Martin has said
that he imagined Aria being there in the
end but her story arc has never focused
that much on the White Walkers I just
can't see what role she would need to
play in this war to come sure she does
have that Valyrian steel dagger now and
maybe she'll end up using it on a white
Walker as it invades the halls of
Winterfell we got to admit that aria is
totally a survivor and would still be
pretty deadly in the winds of winter but
just like Cersei I could see an ending
of Game of Thrones that no longer needs
a vengeful assassin crossing names off
her list
Arya's goals remain short-sighted her
characters never been about the future
or settling down she's much more
exciting to see as this driven killer
so I predict that her story will end
with one last kill that ends her own
life too
maybe a suicide assassination mission
against Cersei or like the mountain or
Melisandre but more on that later
meanwhile I don't see what the show
would gain by killing off Sansa in the
final season since leaving King's
Landing Sansa has made a series of smart
tactical choices proving to be a pretty
savvy Lady of Winterfell she deserves to
survive and carry on her stark family
legacy beyond the end of the series but
moving on to someone who has already
died John or Aegon I guess I'm gonna
stick with John you could say John has
already suffered for his past mistakes
actually lately his character almost
seems a little too invincible like
surviving all of the Battle of the
bastards and the frozen lake expedition
saying that some thick plot armor it
definitely seems like the show is saving
him for a final confrontation with the
night king but beyond that I don't know
if the show really needs him to rule the
future of Westeros it's almost like the
most interesting part of John's life is
what we're seeing in the events of the
show I don't know if I really care about
an epilogue with him the same goes for
the show's other protagonists Daenerys
now I don't think she really deserves
narrative punishment but she's always
been more of a conqueror than a ruler
backed in season 7 the focus with her
shifted more to what comes after she
breaks the wheel having a successor I
think the show's whole purpose of
bringing her and John together was to
produce a child and I think that child
will be their legacy to rule after the
winds of winter have subsided with the
child
being their dream of spring there is
definitely a reason the show chose to
intercut John and Danny's boat sex with
the flashback of the other dragon in the
wolf John's parents Rhaegar and Lyanna
while Tyrion watched outside looking
very concerned we were meant to see this
dragon and wolf as doom not meant to
survive this war just like John's
parents didn't survive that war so I
predict that we're going to see the
death of John perhaps while taking down
the night King and one-on-one combat or
by saving Daenerys in some way meanwhile
I think it's totally plausible that
Daenerys will die in childbirth like her
mother did and like John's mother did
and like Tyrians mother did she's pretty
no health care sucks in this world it's
just after rewarding these two with
rebirth and sparing them from death so
many times I think it would be profound
of the show to end their lives after
their purpose to this overall narrative
has been fulfilled to break the wheel of
the Iron Throne to save Westeros from
the brink and to produce a legitimate
heir to lead the way into the next
generation but the show will need some
leadership reins to help bear that torch
and that's why I think Tyrion will
survive now it's clear george RR martin
has a soft spot for the character and
despite how different martin has tried
to make Game of Thrones from the Lord of
the Rings series I've put a game of
Thrones will end similarly to return the
king with this world finally recognizing
the contribution of the small actually
have a more specific kind of weird
prediction about Tyrion in the final
shot of the series and my other
predictions video and I think this
attention must be paid payoff will also
go for sir Davos and Samwell Tarly in
the final season both of them have spent
their journeys as really the smartest
men in the room whom no one really
listens to who ended up being two of the
most pragmatic sources of conscience and
knowledge in this known world Sam with
book smarts and sir Davos with a sea
smarts and let's face it both of these
guys get an inordinate amount of screen
time clearly the writers love writing
for them and I take that as a good sign
that the show plans to reward these guys
with survival I also think that sets up
the possibility that Sam's survival
along with probably Gilly and her son to
write all of these events down in a new
history text called a song of a nephew
and an aunt keen on a vote or maybe Sam
will come up with something more poetic
meanwhile I don't think Game of Thrones
requires the survival of the Greyjoy's
to make any team at extent both Euron
and Theon have enough blood on their
hands to make their deaths dramatically
justified for Theon actually I think
sacrificing himself or Noble
cause like killing his uncle and
rescuing his sister Yara might be the
only way it can really redeem himself at
this point how the final primary
character here is the knight king we
don't know enough about him to say
whether he deserves to die like is he
even alive did the Terminator deserve
the diabetes that's pretty much what he
is now a big part of me wants to see the
knight Kings succeed in whatever his
goals are like I definitely want to see
him shatter the Iron Throne and reign
Bluefire on all the cities of Westeros
but then what what kind of ending is
that nature wins I think in order for
Game of Thrones to end with enough
satisfaction of the world having changed
the night king and the White Walkers
must be vanquished I just hope that the
show will have enough balls to pay a
heavy price for that victory and Rob a
few main characters of happy storybook
endings now moving on to the rest of the
cast supporting characters can die for
those affirmation reasons as well as
punishment for mistakes or as game
changers but let's face it they can also
die for slightly less meaningful reasons
their deaths can be used to motivate
other characters in action they can be
used to show another character's
treachery and sometimes are killed for
pure shock value to pay off fans wanting
to see them go in the most violent way
possible so will Game of Thrones do this
to any of our beloved supporting
characters yeah I think so so first I
think
beric Dondarrion tormund Giantsbane
Dolores Edie and anyone near the wall is
in serious danger the show just made a
huge statement by closing season 7 with
the night king destroying a chunk of the
wall and I predict they'll kill off at
least one of these characters to add
emotional stakes to the night Kings
threat that said even though I think
he's at the wall right now I think
Gendry is probably safe I don't think
the show would reintroduce him at the
end of season 7 just to kill him off
right away at the beginning of season 8
as the surviving spiritual and genetic
successor to Robert Baratheon
I think he'll carry on his father's
legacy like if Aria doesn't die maybe
he'll join her on whatever her new
adventures are Starks and Baratheon back
together again
now the characters who are protectors
and right-hand Warriors characters like
grey worm Jorah Mormont Brienne bran I
think these guys are all on the chopping
block too for example I could see grey
worm in Jorah dying as tragic foils to
send Danny as well as Masson day
spiraling into despair and guilt however
bran seems like the kind of cunning
survivor who's just ruthless enough but
not totally heartless for the show to
allowed to survive
Brienne as a character has already been
thrown in
way a bear pit as motivation for another
character Janie I could see Jamie coming
to rescue her again or for her to rescue
Jamie but I think for Game of Thrones to
kill her off would undercut the journey
her character is taken Game of Thrones
is a show that celebrates these misfit
toys
so like Tyrion I think Brienne will in
the series rewarded for her life of
torment with tormund or better yet to
the handsomest person in Westeros and by
the way if Brienne survives I think that
would bode well for Podrick as well
I think they'd only kill a Podrick to
make us sad or to teach us a valuable
lesson about STV prevention or Yara
gradually I think one of the great joys
needs to survive to carry on the family
legacy and I predict after you're on at
Theon kill each other off Yara
will survive as the first female leader
of the Iron Islands the rightful winner
of the Kingsmoot in season six now when
it comes to characters like Varys and
lady Melisandre this past season
cryptically foreshadowed their deaths I
have to die in this strange country just
like you in Millis Andrews case I think
that death may come at the hands of Arya
remember back in season 3 when
Melisandre took Kendra she said this to
the girl with a look of fear on her face
I see a darkness in you and in that
darkness eyes staring back at me brown
eyes blue eyes green eyes eyes you'll
shut forever
we will need you again and I predict
Aria will have a chance to fulfill this
promise actually I'm curious to see what
happens here like Melisandre returns to
her true appearance that of an old woman
like in that case Aria would see how
this woman hid herself behind disguises
in order to manipulate people which is a
lot like what Aria does meanwhile for
various I think his death is way more of
a mystery like Melisandre could have
just been implying he'll die in this
strange country just way later in his
life like not in any sudden unexpected
way and as someone who is always claimed
to act for the good of the realm I would
hope that if Varys dies it's in a way
that saves lives for example well maybe
like killing Qyburn to prevent him from
using wildfire to Qyburn down King's
Landing to get the White Walkers out I
think it'd be kind of fun to see these
two like fight it out either way I'm
assuming that if Cersei dies I don't
think her hand Qyburn will survive the
final season either like this guy's past
experimentations are gonna blow up in
his face sooner or later like maybe with
the mountain turning on him like
Frankenstein's monster
or him realizing suddenly that his
machinations he invented to defeat the
night king are useless speaking of the
mountain yeah season seven finale
definitely promise to showdown between
the Clegane brothers it's interesting
that we've actually seen two past duels
displaying the monstrosity of the
mountain a first round against his
brother in season one at the tourney of
the hand and then a second round against
the Viper in season four and the final
season is promising a third act knockout
that I think will be even more violent
you knows coming for you and when we're
talking about the Hound returning the
favor for the facial scars and
confronting his fear of fire the two
qualities that so define his character
wouldn't be an interesting way to make
the hounds death meaningful but I kind
of feel like we're old a reunion between
the hound and Arya it's actually
interesting how these two have affected
each other so much that their
personalities have essentially flip Aria
has become more of a ruthless killer
while the Hound has become a more
empathetic conscience driven softy so I
would love to see both of their final
chapters intertwine putting themselves
in harm's way for each other in one last
duo suicide mission maybe for both of
them to go after the villain each of
them want to kill the most a mountain
and Cersei Lannister now there are a
bunch of other even smaller characters
that could get interesting deaths but I
could also see the show not bothering to
wrap up their stories at all at mere
Tolle
Robb Arryn jock and a garli in a more
mod the Citadel arch masters Sam's
mother and sister Daario naharis we'll
see what happens with the
guys but instead I want to end on the
beloved beasts of this show the
remaining direwolf's ghosts in Ameria
and the Dragons drogon and regal and the
resurrected white dragon Vaziri on other
than Missouri on I don't want any of
these animals to die I kind of hate it
when the pets have to go now in the past
Game of Thrones has historically used
these animals as scapegoat figures
taking a bullet for a primary character
in order to save them to spare them
blame or to increase the shock value of
their humans deaths and of course in
Missourians case it was to change the
game in my other predictions video I
predicted that we'll see a dragon
against dragon battle in the final
season so unfortunately I do think we'll
lose another dragon maybe all three and
I really do worry that if the last two
dire wolves return it'll be to sacrifice
their lives for John and Arya the way
some are did for bran and if my
predictions are right that John and Arya
don't survive in a series I don't think
their dialogues will either that said
George our Martin has promised that the
ending will feel bittersweet I think if
the Dragons die it would be very
interesting for them to do a similar
thing with Drogo nor ragel that I'm
predicting the show will do with Jon and
Daenerys leave a legacy as a
metaphorical dream of spring and I think
in the Dragons case take the form of a
dragon egg think of it this way if the
final season does end with the death of
John aka Aegon which is commonly
shortened to egg
maybe instead another egg will be around
to keep their baby warm
so to recap people I think will die next
season Cersei Arya
John Danny Theon urine in the night King
and the Dragons the direwolves the
mountain the Hound
Melisandre Varys Barrack Jorah tormund
grey worm and Qyburn leaving the
survivors as Sansa Jaime bran Sam Gilly
sir Davos Brienne bran Gendry Yara
Masson day
Podrick John and Danny's kid and a
dragon egg wow that is a lot of dead
characters that we love anyway tell me
how accurate you think these predictions
are who do you think will be the most
shocking death of the final season will
the show have the nerve to kill off John
ordinary sir Arya let's keep this
conversation going in the comments below
you can tweet any predictions or
theories that you have to me a TA vos or
follow new rock stars at new rock stars
for updates about our videos can share
this video and subscribe to new rock
stars for more Game of Thrones video
we want to keep discussing Game of
Thrones throughout the months between
now and season eight and you can help us
decide exactly what kind of videos to do
by joining our team and contributing to
us on patreon we actually created a poll
where our patrons can weigh in on what
kind of subjects to cover so get on that
join the team and a big thanks to all of
our donors especially Kenny Smith
alright thanks for watching bye